let's say we're having a birthday party
and these are the kids at the birthday
party and all the kids they have a bunch
of different ages and what we are
curious about is how many kids of each
age do we have
well to help think about that we can
draw what is called a line pot and i've
always viewed the term line plot a bit
confusing because in my brain you use a
lot more dots than you use lines but
let's look at what a line plot is
so what i will do is i will draw i guess
this involves a line right over here
i'll draw a line down here and then i'll
create buckets for each of the ages so
let's see i have students here from age
three all the way to age seven so i
could say age three
age four
age five age six and age seven i don't
have to go to two or i don't have to go
to eight there aren't any kids in those
in those ages although i could if i want
and then i look at well how many kids do
i have of each age
well i have one
one
one person attending the party dia she's
age three so i would put i might put an
x here or i could put a dot here
different line plots would put different
things here but that shows me that i
have this this this this partier is age
three right over here now i have imran
age five so that's someone
that's someone right over here who'd be
h5 you could think of this dot this
represents imran who's age five
then you have surya who's also age five
so he's also age five so that means we
have a second
we have a second person at the party who
is age five so under age five we now
have two people this is iran and this is
surya
then you have jasper who is six
so that's one person who is age six then
you also have vikram who is age six
oops let me do that in that same color
we also have vikram who is age six so
let's put him in the age six bucket then
we have luke who is seven
luke who is seven
so that would be a dot right over there
and then finally i have anya who's also
age six
who is also age six
so just like that i was able to take all
of the data that i have in this table
and i were i'm able to put it on this
line plot and the reason why this line
plot is useful is it helps us look at
well
how many of each age do we have it might
be a little bit more confusing to just
look at the table here because when you
look at the line plot it's very clear
hey look there's no one here who is age
four and look we have the most people
who are age six and if we ask ourselves
a question well how many if you didn't
even have this actually let me just even
take it away
if we didn't even have that there if we
didn't have the table and we just had
the line plot and if someone said hey
look you know these are ages right over
here
this is our ages in years old
and each dot represents a student who's
at the party
so based on this line plot how many
people are more than five years old
well you could look at this and you
could say okay more than five years old
that would be six years old or seven
years old it's not showing anyone who's
eight nine ten eleven and on and on and
on and on so let's look at all the dots
let's all look at all the dots here that
are more than five years old there are
three six-year-olds and there's one
seven-year-old so there are one two
three four people who are older than
five years old
you could do go the other way around you
could say how many people are less than
five years old well then you can say
okay less than five years old would be
either three years old or four years old
and when you look at those dots you see
there's only one dot only one person
attending the party is less than five
years old hopefully you found that
hopefully you found that interesting